foreign
I got a quick one for you okay this is a
explainer start talk explainer on area
codes oh oh okay area code really yeah
everything what an uh now see here's
what I'm gonna do what are you gonna do
I am going to open my mind stay open I'm
going to be receptive because you know
in the times past where you have come up
with some cockamami stuff
I have said to myself this Amanda lost
his mind this is like one of the
smartest people I've ever met in my
entire life it's finally happened I'm
going off the deep end and he wants to
talk about you know so but and then at
the end I'm like oh man that was that
was pretty dope that was deep okay so
instead of having my normal reaction
when something is different and you have
trained yourself you've learned myself
I'm gonna be like you know what
Bring It On so you know before a certain
time if you see phone numbers in
old-timey TV shows uh they only gave
seven numbers they didn't give an area
code and because area codes had to be
sort of formulated and figured out by
the phone company that if you were going
to dial on your own that they needed a
way to direct the call to the proper
location instead of calling the operator
the operator get me uh something so it's
not in New York or in Los Angeles or in
right so now you can dial it directly so
this is a big advance in people's
ability to communicate without the help
of a telephone operator all right so now
let's go back to the dial phone
okay okay all right so in the dial phone
you stuck your finger in the hole and
you rotated the dial all the way to this
little finger stopper right hold your
finger out and then it clicked all its
way back
okay by the way each one of those clicks
was itself an acoustic instruction to
the phone to dial that number oh if you
which I owned at the time something that
just simply makes clicking sounds you
just pick up the phone and attach it to
the to the speaker I mean to the to the
uh the microphone you know the bottom
part of the phone and then it can you
can click your phone number into the
phone system without actually dialing
okay but that was like short-lived
because then we had touch tone in this
but let's go back to the dial phone okay
so the number one
was all the way at the top right and had
the shortest distance to go
to get to the finger stopper so you have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and then what came after nine zero
zero or oh oh for operating for operator
okay so that one you're bringing around
that was like 10 clicks right okay all
the way around by the way I worked for
a t Bell labs when I was in college I
had a summer internship there oh at
um Murray Hill oh which was the research
headquarters in New Jersey I saw weed
out of a phone booth once
[Laughter]
we should be friends
foreign
so anyhow uh so that sensitized me to
the history of phones and the long lines
and the and why long distance calls were
so expensive because they used that the
profits from that to pay for everything
else which is why making a normal phone
call was not very expensive so in the
day you'd make a long distance phone
call you told the people you were
calling along and said I'm making a you
know I'm calling long distance they
would drop everything to accommodate you
because everyone knew that that was
costing some real cash it's got some
money no that's not what they would
think he said we gotta we gotta help out
so that my bell doesn't end up with all
our money all right that was the
collective understanding here all right
so
time for area codes all right well they
already had a set of digits that were
reserved for certain uh tasks so four
one one if you type 411 that was
reserved for information
you dial 4-1-1 and you'd get a human
telephone book basically what is the
number of Johnny Jones whatever Mary
Smith in this at this address they'd
look it up and sometimes they'll dial it
for you or they would just tell it to
you and you'd write it down wow okay
yeah this is like forever ago all right
so 611 would be if there's something
wrong with your phone and you needed
repairs okay okay so they said we'll be
by tomorrow to look at the phone line
whatever right so they had a few of
these that all had a a one
um in the middle okay
however those were established
after
area codes were established okay now
they knew we're not going to have a
phone number beginning with a one
nor a phone number beginning with a zero
right here we go
if you can't begin a number with one
right
and the next two digits can't be a one
and a one okay
so what's left
so the highest population city New York
they wanted that
to be where the area code
can be dialed the quickest
because the most number of people would
be dialing it that's right and you don't
want to burden so many people with
waiting around for the dial to finish
dialing
that's right because you're going with
the finger thing with the finger thing
can't have two one one so you gotta have
two one two two one two is the shortest
time dialed area code on a dial yo
that's cool okay so now what city has
the next highest population probably Los
Angeles Los Angeles what is the area
code of Los Angeles
that's why you have this okay okay
what's the next most popular city
probably Chicago Chicago what's the area
code of Chicago I don't know it but I'm
sure it's two one four no no no oh I can
go lower than that three one two oh
three one two that's right
that's wrong cause you're staying in the
flute
you staying in that little you standing
three finger holes the three-hole
standard of Excellence so
okay so we took out two one two two one
three three one two okay
now uh what's the next most populous
city
um um after Chicago yeah wow that's
tough now I'm now I'm losing let me see
I'm trying to think uh I'm trying to
think back then what it would be because
yeah actually I don't remember
because now it might be you know there's
so many we're all over the place yeah
but those three main cities you get the
point yeah of this and they wanted to
minimize the time you would spend
dialing in a long distance call
people who are in these most populated
cities so if you were to go back there
it probably you're looking at something
like Philadelphia
after I was wondering Houston too I have
to check my map again it has to be back
then yeah let's see
one five so maybe there's something area
code 213
12 yeah two one five that's close
let's just ask who 214 is let me find
out all right area code uh two one four
Dallas two one four all right give it to
me okay and how about three one four
what's three one three
I'm a three one three let's see three
one three Detroit that makes sense there
you go these are all heavily popular
heavily populated cities and let's try
three one four
and that's why it's St Louis so these
are big cities these are big cities it
goes around it's not just some
systematic incrementing of numbers
they were looking out for you this these
are smart people physicists Engineers
developing the future of communication
and they got so smart they were like why
the hell don't we just have push buttons
great idea
right she just have push buttons
somebody was like George is right
right so push money don't make any
difference anymore right makes no
difference and so and then the
population went up not not only did the
population go up but everybody now has
three or four phone numbers associated
with themselves absolutely you have your
home phone number right you have your
cell phone number you have your work
phone number if you work and you have a
desk and then that's at least three so
so once the phone number is proliferated
then the municipalities needed more than
one area code and then then and then we
with push button it all bets are off it
just didn't matter it doesn't really
matter now you have area codes that
sound like the beginning of a phone
number right because they started all
area codes so it with the one in the
middle then they put a zero in the
middle when you had Touch Tone right and
that sort of smelled like an area code
73707 204 204 right you got everything
now you got everything three nine one
seven you got six four six right is that
area code yeah yeah
so that's all I want to tell you ah well
that was fun who knew that's wrong New
York Los Angeles
Chicago
nice there you go they just didn't want
you to wear out your fingers
that makes sense you know
um oh oh so I got one for you
uh so what is the area code
of Cape Canaveral Cape Canaveral
I need Jeopardy music here
yeah I mean I would have no idea okay
are you ready go ahead
the area code of Cape Canaveral is three
two one
I'm duh of course they launched rockets
at Cape Canaveral right it is three two
one and they they worked hard to get
that that's not the chance thing right
they work they they lobbied for that
they they they they got that and who's
gonna say no who's going to deny that
exactly of course not but I of course
not
um and so there was an episode of
Seinfeld when area codes were
proliferating where they created a
social class around who had a 212 area
code remember Seinfeld took place New
York City that's a big deal and someone
said oh they're like ready to date and
they said well what's your phone number
and he says oh it's six four six six
four six what where do you live I don't
I don't trust you yeah who are you
so it created this social riff between
those who were like in and those who
weren't yeah and to this day they're New
Yorkers with cell phone numbers some of
which are 212. yeah and so that those
are badass long Old Timers nobody wants
to give up the two one two but that's
right they might have had cell phones
back when they were shoulder mounted
right you know exactly and what I liked
about the New York uh so they they
isolated the 212 area code to just
Manhattan right and then they introduced
718 for all of the outer boroughs so so
Queens Brooklyn uh and the Bronx and
Staten Island and then initially cell
phones were all 917s and then they added
six four sixes so New York City has at
least four and there's a fifth one three
four seven I think it is three four
seven yeah so we have five area codes in
just the New York City area and that's
just because people do a lot of damn
talking there you go what that is so so
now you're in the know for the area code
yeah and it's a very it's just a slice
of history when dial phones was a thing
right and you realize solutions to some
problems are rendered obsolete by later
advances in technology but at the time
they were quite clever and I'd like to
just give a shout out to people who were
trying to make life better for us all
that's very cool yeah that's very cool
Frozen in time and in space well my cell
service I might as well have a rotary
phone
this meant a lot to me oh another thing
in uh what's that TV show with Mork from
orc um
so uh Robin Williams plays an alien
who's visiting Mindy and
I what I liked is he the way he does he
picked up a phone and he'd whistle out
the touch tones and that's how he dialed
the phone and that was just I just
thought that was badass that's pretty
cool I wanted to be able to do that and
I and you don't have to be an alien to
have that ability but you have to be
like on this perfect and when I was a
kid I had this book called fun with the
telephone right and you could dial like
nursery rhymes with the tones
Mary had a little lamp you know
63.3 and so you could play music on it
and you'd accidentally occasionally dial
people you just I'm sorry I'm just
playing with the phone and then you do
that so I go way back with telephones
nowadays you would have sampled that and
you'd be uh playing Madison Square
Garden
there it is all right Chuck that's all
we have time for that was cool man that
was great all right this has been a
stark talk explainer Neil deGrasse Tyson
here with Chuck nice as always keep
looking up
oh
[Music]